[Aplausos]
oscar wilde decía dale una máscara a un
hombre y te dirá la verdad
la idea de que el lenguaje transforma la
conciencia humana derivando en
diferentes formas de pensamiento
me ha llevado a cuestionarme del poder
que tienen las palabras sobre nosotros
y eso es lo que me ha definido como
escritora porque a pesar de que tengo
una carrera muy joven
ya que en el 2010 se publicó mi primer
libro cuando el infierno se congele
realmente puedo decir que me convertí en
ello hace apenas unos años
casualmente un día como hoy pero del
2014 en el día de mi boda estaba
embarazada de conocimiento
así que hoy estoy de celebración
que celebró
no solo mi aniversario de matrimonio
sino el hecho de por primera vez poner
en palabras una verdad que me ha costado
muchísimo trabajo de ingerir
porque me expresé con una metáfora de mi
embarazo
debido a que ocho días después de haber
dado a luz la vida de mi hermosa bebé se
transformó en algo más en algo etéreo
debido a una cardiopatía
nunca me imaginé
estar en la posición de enterrar a un
hijo
pero eso el haberme roto en mil pedazos
y ver como demonios juntaban las piezas
para renacer
es lo que me trajo estar aquí hoy con
ustedes
perdón
estas flores
significaron para mí algo súper agresivo
al momento del duelo de mi hija
muchas personas me dieron el pésame
mediante muestras de afecto o mediante
llamadas emails pero hubo una pareja que
me regaló unas flores
era obvio que no celebraba nada porque
alguien te va a regalar unas flores
honestamente me sentía agredida cada que
pasaba por mi casa y veía estas flores
era un recordatorio
pero sin lugar a dudas estas flores me
fueron acompañando poco a poco en el
duelo en el proceso porque fueron
pasando los días mi situación física y
emocional era bastante delicada y tuve
que estar en cama varias semanas
fue lo que hice me refugié en mi
computadora en mis libros en estar en
contacto en gente leer mucho
y entendí que la gente se comunica y
habla a partir de la batalla personal
que se encuentra librando o desde el
lugar en donde nace
entendí que hay una relación intrínseca
entre el lenguaje y la comunicación no
verbal porque hubieran palabras que se
quedaron tatuadas en mi mente y fue
justo ahí
cuando encontré el significado de la
palabra lenguaje que quiere decir estilo
y modo de hablar y escribir de cada
persona en particular pero si se dan
cuenta este significado es muy simple y
deja a un lado todo lo que sucede atrás
del pensamiento todo lo que sucede atrás
del lenguaje
por ello
escribió un texto
llamado
palabras que los padres jamás quisieran
pronunciar
texto explora
el proceso de cómo afrontamos la muerte
y fue justo ahí en ese momento
ya habían pasado seis meses desde que
había nacido mi hija laura que recibió
una llamada de mi doctor en la que me
dijo bueno una laura
estás esperando hay que ponerse las
pilas y hay que empezar se embarazaría
que hay que ponerse las pilas loco que
colgué le marqué a mi marido
y le dije que se me había hecho bastante
fuerte el hecho que me dijeran eso
porque realmente seis meses es muy poco
tiempo de duelo el alma sigue doliendo
porque una perdida
tiene las mismas consecuencias que una
herida o una quemadura
lleva tiempo a que regrese a su origen
lleva tiempo a que sane
pero algo hicieron estas palabras
en mí
normalmente no en mi memoria no en mi a
nivel del alma me fueron acompañando y a
lo largo de tres meses estaba embarazada
por segunda ocasión
y vaya circo que fue ese segundo
embarazo
en verdad no titubeó en decirles
no dormí durante 38 semanas y tenía un
nivel de estrés a tope todo el tiempo
viendo si se movía el bebé si no se
movía y respiraba sí esto sí el otro
y justo cuando estaba en medio del
trabajo de parto que duró 24 horas y
acabo necesaria para hacer esto
interesante una de las enfermeras que me
estaba asistiendo llegó me tomó de la
mano me dijo verme a los ojos
dijo por qué luchas
mi hijo lleva luchando desde que
llegaste estás luchando contra el dolor
contra la contracción contra tu cuerpo
contra tu respiración
dijo con las contracciones
no se lucha
se les abraza se les acepta
así como cuando vas a la playa no luchas
contra las olas las aprendes a pasar y
ya está en ti si decides brincar las o
pasarlas por debajo dependiendo la
profundidad de la que te encuentres
entonces eso fue lo que hice
no luche contra la contracción las
aprendí a pasar
meses después me encontraba ya con mi
hija se fuera en brazos
si le puse el nombre de una tienda mi
hija
se fuera quiere decir belleza o ave que
emprende el vuelo
[Música]
y entendí que justo lo que hice en el
duelo de mi hija laura fue lo que pasó
en el trabajo de parto con sephora
no luche contra la gravedad de la
situación
acepte su muerte cuando ella estaba viva
entendí que había pocas opciones y
aprendí a pasar las oleadas de dolor del
tiempo que lleve en desarrollarse el
duelo para sanar una herida
entendí
el agua se evapora
pero regresa a la tierra como lluvia
en ese momento la palabra muerte tenía
un efecto muy grande sobre nosotros
un poder poder que no podíamos permitir
siguiera teniendo
como escritora esto me llevó
a retomar una novela que llevaba 13 años
escribiendo de manera intermitente
titulada rescátame de la muerte y que se
publicará cuando sea el momento correcto
una novela
en donde el planteamiento de la muerte
las consecuencias y la evolución y los
giros argumentales de cada personaje
estaban mal
porque los duelos
no hay palabrerías
en los duelos hay dolor
en la muerte hay silencio
y mi novela tenía setecientos y tantas
páginas
y obviamente no puede haber palabrería
entonces que hice durante cuatro meses
me dediqué a asesinar la novela me puse
en el modo escritora en el que no haces
nada interrumpes tu vida
y te dedicas a asesinar la novela
despiadadamente
y de repente en un abrir y cerrar de
ojos 320 páginas
cobraron vida
se convirtió en una novela nueva nació
junto conmigo
pasando esto
y una especie de revelación una catarsis
una noche una madrugada me levanté
de un salto
y pude ver las conexiones entre los
seres humanos y las palabras en ese
momento la palabra muerte
ya no tenía poder sobre mí ni sobre mi
marido
se había ido
no había recibido a mi mamá un
diagnóstico de cáncer
entonces esto nuevamente me saco de mi
centro
un nuevo duelo
y me entero por tercera ocasión
estoy embarazada
me entero cuando tenía tres meses de
embarazo porque estaba teniendo un
embarazo asintomática
yo creo
que mis emociones mis emociones se
fueron por eso no sentí nada
y el haber me ha embarazado esa tercera
ocasión
me llevo
a recobrar mis sentimientos
porque cuando uno se encuentra en medio
de la tormenta el común denominador te
dice lucha sé fuerte sé valiente
y aquí tengo que enfatizar un rotundo no
en esas palabras no encuentro ningún
tipo de cuestionamiento esas palabras no
te empoderan tienes que encontrar el por
qué estás parado ahí porque tu vida está
teniendo ese cambio porque tu vida está
teniendo ese giro porque si no lo vas a
volver a vivir
no es hasta que encuentras el porqué
en mi caso
la respuesta estuvo en una enfermera
los significados se encuentran en la
gente
para que encuentras porque puedes
experimentar paz
y una vez que estás en paz
sueltas
sueltas la situación
sueltas esa alma que vino aquí con un
motivo específico
solamente cuando sueltas
mágicamente las cosas fluyen
y ahí
justo ahí es cuando uno aprende cuál es
la mejor manera de pasar una ola gracias